>>> BREAKING NEW
TW CNN TIE-HOSTS, NNND
HOST ANNA NAVARRO HAVEOWATSAS A
PCREST.
IN AND NAVATE TOLD TO LEAVE
VI             TV THIS MORNST BR
>> THERE SEEMSBEHING
HA100% AWARE OF.SOMEONE PLEASE F
>> NEED THE TWO OF YOU TO
OFF FOR A SECOND. >>>> ANN -- A
>>ES
HE VICE
PRESIDENT?
>> OKAVICE PRESIDENT --
>> NO?
>> NO.
>> OKAY.
LET'S .E
>>S US NOW.
,  HAPPENED?
THROUGH WHAT HAPPENED? FEELING
RS SAY THANK YOU TE WELL-WISHER.
THERE'S BEEN P
SOCIAL MEDIA WLL.
AND G AN TICE
ID, KAMALA
HARRIS, EL T
NA.
I WANT TO
SERVEY WEROU
KNOW, AND -- AND T T
IT TAKES SO MUCH WORK TO DO KE
SOMETHAT WE WERE
HAVE THE QUESTI
VICERESINT
VIEW."
AND THEN SRNED ISO
R TH SOW OFTEN ARE
>> I'M TESVE-
EVERTI- , I
BUILDING. ERE AL W OF MEASURES"
THS -- YOU K LIKE IN
THHE --
ON THE FOR.YBODY'S WEARMASKS,
ON
YOU KNOW?
>> I JUST NTITF -- IT IS-
SOMETHING T NG TO WATCH.
LET'S JUST WATCH THIS.>>RE SEEO
ARISITUATION?OFOUF FOR A SECO .
WE HAD --
Y T
WHOIYOUR MIND AT THIS POINT?D A
TOLD.
WCHTIS ILE WE ARE SITTINGRE
BECAUSE OF COVID, --
THE TABLATS LIKE
SO JOYHE OTHERR.
SI
I DON'T THINSHE SEES
OFN SUNND
THIS IS HAPPENING AND, OF AWKWAR
IT'S, YOU KNOW, PUZZNG
>> OH, I SEE.
SO -- SO    AYS THE THING OF
LIKE STUFF IS ENING I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT IANKEE
THAT'S MY JOIMPRESSION.
YOU HAD ALREADY BEEN TOLOR SOME?
>> WE HA BEEN TOLDN OUR
EARSAR
LIKE WHAT?
WHATT Y?YO
>> AND THIS IS IN THE
>> S >> AND AS YOU KNOW, ANDERS
TRYING -- UST GO ON., YOU KNOW,E
>> SO WHAT HAPPENS T SERYONE
LIKA?
PPENS? WELL,OUERE --K.
TO T BACKSTAGE.CEN A
WE HAD HAD NCO
DUNGY.
>> AND -- AND SO, THEY ARE
UT WHASAFE WAY TCONDUCT THIS
ENNG THE -- TH--W DO WE DO THIST
W FROM THAT ROOM
REMOTE IN HER EARS WHILE WE WE N
AND WEOOK ACK FALSE
POSITIVE FOR ME.
.A
IT'SO TALK ABOUT HER
TEST RESULTS.
RND
E.FLY HOME TO MIAMI AND